someone is going to later care about the
citizens
hope you guys are doing well welcome to
another show of ask the chef I'm table
shall hasten about good evening light
chatter this Jeremiah hi did you always
get it wrong yes these are quite shet
hate them just make them okay alright so
much your secular headed Heidi how are
you nestled some peanuts awesome
Jefferson goodness I'm gonna yes what do
I do
what how do you say in any and I'm okay
in and Eve a really awesome yeah you say
Mexico City are you yeah and you can say
send me then I was even yes send letters
on yes or muscle sin is necessarily how
are you guys yes guys how are guys yeah
how to respect yes yes you know the
first a statement I learned in in order
yes that may night or do both the who
again people will laugh now okay that I
don't speak on to and some money
it's a leave other people that they are
you know English no I don't see in the
air
yes okay just okay let's get straight
into inshallah don't speak copy of not
know how is it all just you know like
okay yeah yeah just remind me I wish it
make sure you basically last last
episode we had we gave a photo about
sista specific situation had to welcome
to a supermarket if she had to tell
alcohol touch poor etc however there was
nothing understanding and we can go into
detail because I don't know if you saw
it from the video I was very scared of
the height yes I think so that's why I
rushed the video of it yeah so we didn't
get the chance to go in detail so what
we're going to do is we're going to talk
about that so that's being talked about
ready what we're gonna do is we're going
to understand where this comes from
where is this idea of because we know
what Hara yeah so we're in the religion
this idea of something Haram become
become a halal where do we get the song
share you are you taking this from
yourself are you taking this from the
Quran and Sunnah etc unjust I said then
would advocate I just want to know [ __ ]
wait where do this idea come from around
become in Holland in what situation and
who decides this yeah okay
this Allah
that's what the point are you you know
this idea is confirmed in Sharia okay it
is confirmed in Sharia and there are
number of evidences that confirmed that
this does exist okay necklace for
example allah allah allah said heard a
metallic coming later to a demo animals
in GD okay
sorry Natalie coming later to a demo -
moves until you will now you can get
arising that to be he won one Holly 41
more food that one motor ability enough
you had Rama I collect several in them
they play to my mother you had a muscle
I was ill I listed all the Haram think
that you should not eat okay then a
large analysis from a new problem royal
rather know that the concept of family
program but berola Ghidorah
yes it transfers some Harlem's
into what what is the deny that the rule
means necessary necessary of an example
yes
for example if a person is about to die
and he doesn't find accept Hallam needs
to consume okay then it might be
obligatory upon him to consume the Haram
meet in order to us survive in order to
survive
okay yeah that's okay also in terms of
Allah Allah Allah said in a man Oklahoma
album of my humble a manual action man
charitable Cofidis Allah the one who is
pushed to say a statement of cover in
lemon Oh Korea not sure yes statement of
work or [ __ ] yes he can utter that
statement by his tongue and otherwise
Eliza's workable not manually man as far
as his heart is what is established on
in map you can utter that statement okay
okay if he was subject to a severe
punishment and the punishment that
cannot be bad okay that he cannot death
so does that mean that these situation
always have to be lessened death
okay no not necessary another example is
one when the last whadya la jolla angle
head to the Prophet Elias and the day
torture
didn't torture me I come out to be
repaired yes yeah
and they ask me to this video yes and
then banana he used to say a statement
that is mainly not clear he used to say
I hadn't I had I had aa okay yeah and
the focus of our solemn allowed him okay
okay to use a statement like this in
order to earth to listen the punishment
or the torching same thing with a
marvelous and unchanging with others
with kebab and Agassi
so it is confirmed this is confirmed in
Syria now this is not a matter of life
and death
this colors have written books about the
principle of the ruler and the plant
that the principle of Guevara and one it
allows the Haram fancy and that's why
the scholars have classified the Hara
the Haram is not of one level okay for
example sheikh yes yes in the shape
telugu malavika Nevada and run you shall
carry Allah does not forgive [ __ ]
because church is the highest level of
this one invested and mafia okay then
okay that is not like a swearing word
okay yes
stealing 1 million yes pounds is not
lightly stealing one pound
yes composure or constant the eight
levels okay raping an innocent lady yes
is it not
although it is severe and thinner is sit
weirdness but it is not like okay
Xena yeah in fact winner of an old
person is more punishable than Xena
committed by young person yes yes that
lesson is another thing that's why the
prophet solomon islands for example said
tell i certainly under long rahim allah
is a kimono rather than ordinary people
allah allah does not look at them on the
Day of Resurrection and they will be
punished what type who shine upon them
one of them is a shame upon them an old
personality what befalls imprisoners
adage at that age and why why
what was it exactly and his urge to do
zina do not like the age of the urge to
do zina of a young person okay in fact
in fact so shows almost justice exactly
in fact remodels October of the allah
tala he introduced the punishment of
those who drink yes it was mentioned
this is amazing
we used to flog a t-slots those who a
drink if they are young people on this
front but if they are weak he used to
flog them 40 times
so this is at least as great a
discrimination but this is to one to
consider the situations or okay that
also shows what that he has leniency
because somebody can say how you change
the normal life is eighty if you're
judgmental fourteen yes but you might
even Khattab with this yes so so even in
situation boxes we can understand that
if we look at it from a general
perspective if you want a bit narrow
mind you say how do you change it by a
few understanding religion yeah go in
detail and the rest proper understanding
there and you understand why the Sahab
insanity by DTX fund all major sins are
not like what - this is confirmed as a
source B minor since the problem of
money on your fabulous I said with a
kana he said a fella
- father - Salah yeah it works you since
yes ok ok
between Salah and your Salah if you need
further further that's all I would want
you send yes yes it was wife which since
the minor thing not the major sense ok
ok the major sins need Toba so therefore
ok now if there is a minor sin
yes yeah there is a minor haba there is
a minor sin but the consequences of
falling into it yeah are grave I mean
sorry the consequence is of not to do
and get the are great okay
yeah so you have two options either you
committed minor sin or the consequences
are so great so what do you do in this
case especially son - yeah why because
if you do not
the minor sin you are committing what
medicine the measures and yeah no one
would say yeah no one would say no one
would understand how shady our okay
leave sherry I'll leave Sharia yeah
just common sense common sense yes no
one would say no commit to the minor sin
sorry no one say abstain from the minor
sin but fall into the major here exact
akhaten any normal so no one will say
this yeah Eve again in our normal life
yes okay in you are about to lose this
transaction or this deal in order to get
a bigger deal everyone say no get the
better deals leave this small deal okay
this is something confirmed and there
are so many examples on a little
circular sector how about it it is
really important is a lot you to do this
unfortunately yes I am a young people a
lot of young people here when it's the
necessity yes they have sympathy egg
their time it's other than yes but when
it's for no other when it comes other
personal sensitive its stuff on us la la
la you are compromising on your religion
we are telling down the rail again valid
like law is that this is my point why
about this because so Bhavana city so we
can understand clearly that would we go
through when it comes a matter of
necessity me and you can't we are not on
that level to understand that we go to
back to the scholars you know and then
we understand that the chef set the
parameter nawaz necessity how it works
so hope you guys kind of grasp and
understand insurance the civil situation
so I understand about ancestry yes you
might look at something and it might be
like wrong but understand the situation
behind that because when it's very
physically with a car for example you
say I need my car in reality do you
really need it but we don't question now
would you say look at the scholars edit
let's go
but let's not have double standards
understand the other person you know
different you know different stuff okay
better for my future okay that's really
good now let's get to the nitty-gritty
now I want you to understand this and
eventually they can understand it is
understanding it was something that
involves them yeah yeah one thing that
we can all say that a lot of us have in
common in the car yeah we either drive
it or we know somebody that drives it
now I was thinking about the chef now if
I'm not mistaken one of the reasons why
insurance is Haram
obviously when you drive a car you need
assurance is that it has a form of the
transactions I'm not moving there are
some aspects of gambling involved yeah
and there might be some kind of river
yes if I'm not mistaken please correct
me yeah some scholar said the
transaction paying monthly yeah that can
be some this image I said it's not
however let's say you have an accident
yeah and you say okay look if you have
an accident and it fails for you a
larger amount than what you gave here
you can reject it however if it's for
example you've hit three cars
the total is hundred thousand pounder
how you gonna clean out your pocket yeah
you're gonna have no choice but maybe to
accept that yeah
so we can say an aspect of limousine
with involved yes so now what I want to
understand chef is how is it permissible
when we know there's two major sins and
that should not be a non negative
excellent didn't they just embody with
the transaction will be known yeah yeah
okay okay okay do that colossal okay let
us take this a bit about good cases
buddy okay insurance why it is how long
yes okay those two scholars will say
that it is otherwise it huh yes exactly
as you said because of the three main
reasons however this is clutch of either
yes
the first reason is Arriba okay how how
okay it is not exactly like what you
said talk about air even when it's
involved that you pay your premium okay
and then the compensation is money okay
only when the compensation is money then
it is a river so this is not money and
if it is not money then there is no
debug what would mean what can where
else can be system money yeah for
example your car yes there is a
difference between they say to you you
paid a monthly installment there from
him yes and if your car has any problem
we will pay you money okay
this is the river one okay because it is
money for more money and as we all know
that the professor a salon said gold for
gold
so money for money as the hadith of the
Prophet SAW salem what the products are
ten of the money for the products are
talented the hub for the go
the grain should be grain for grain
wheat for with etc body for body so for
so it has to be light for lightness and
on the spot okay okay as the profit is a
limitation because this is the tarantula
genius of what the Prophet SAW Solomon
so if there is money for money okay
which is essentially the gold for gold
yes then we have to be careful any
transaction that has money for money
then the what is alarming Bell children
children okay yeah dad this is the
loudest noise from on antenna is a big
thing like when a dog all right of
religion Warren around is like working
war against Allah and the Prophet Allah
male 7 said the analogue Oh Reba al
Qaeda woman kill the hotel to go wash
every day Allah says the one who eats
riba yeah give the river you know the
one who writes the contrast of river and
those who witnessed that construct a box
from there is not a any building a bit
since well with it
okay nothing okay and by the way this
little bomb yeah
it is an interesting destroy but anyway
I'll answer it later because in case
backs okay so we are people yeah so
divine yeah yeah it is a as we say not
in all know no insurance it turns out
okay
okay so for example if you pay insurance
if you pay your premium okay and you
receive service yes they give you a car
when your car broke down or breaks down
okay or they give you they fix your car
they don't give you money
also now there is no money for what more
money over the element of River is
absent yeah
see in any transaction in any
transaction yes the biggest thing that
we need to be worried about now is what
Reba
yes if there is no Reba just random that
now this just means the matter is what
easier okay yes of course
we are not talking about cheating yeah
this we are not talking about teaching
we are talking about clear the TransAm
yes yes no cheating
and know why old risks of it like
meaning if you have a big accident and
the claim is big they will come to that
but they're cheating they clear that you
well I'm not a believer okay okay we are
tossing the rod clear the transaction
where there is no cheating or if there
is an order some dinner then you look at
the second thing okay is there gambling
so what is combination yeah
gambling briefly gambling is earning
money based on luck
okay the two things have to be there
okay earning money or earning any not
necessarily cash yeah okay I'm kind of
earning something based on the luck okay
yes drawing lots
doana you will get this okay yeah okay
this is if it is earning this just based
on lock right with with with one one
condition
yeah you pay money in order to earn this
money based on luck okay so have
insurance fall into that yeah just a
minute
yes again so earning money based on luck
but provided that you pay the money in
order to get into that competition hmm
for example if they say that okay you
are shopping in any test code whatever
Oh like they have these big cars and
they say if you give one pound and we
will pick yes somebody yes
this is earning money but you pay for
that in order a general into your
competition and it's not it's not
because you're not doing anything please
wait and see yes this is like a link or
color that if you are entering yes and
they say take this ticket
yes you don't say anything even one
pound you don't take it just take it and
then we will draw lots and you might a
window the top yes you can do it so
that's not that's not something that is
not gambling because you did not pay
money in order to get into okay a
competitor okay okay the canal insurance
with insurance you pay money yeah yeah
and you might learn some
this unlock okay in insurance that can
happen because you don't know your car
might have this or that etc okay so the
aspect of jump in the end if the
gambling is not that means you know what
is the what you are going to get yeah
they know what they are going to give
you it clearly
yes it is not like drawing gluttonous so
the element of gambling is not clear in
it okay yeah so hamdulillah okay we are
more you're getting closer to full
health
yes really is a second okay now the
third thing about insurance you
indicated success how severe is gambling
before mom second surah my the first 90
Allah mentioned alcohol and gambling yes
gambling is a clear gambling definitely
with this is an algorithm okay okay
the clear gambling yes that the clear
gambling is as well as recite me you
give money yes in order to earn money
based on longing okay but in the
insurance you give money not to earn
money based on that however if your
intention all this then you are falling
into a gamble okay so is this dangerous
dangerous in some cases and so now you
can all can all cases or yeah alright so
this is the second point which is
gambling the third point is what is
transactions on them yes Lara
yes the Prophet SAW said I'm not a
Navarro Radha and the Prophet SAW Salim
prohibited also from transaction that
are unknown okay okay but this color
says why a lot of this uncertainty and
the some objection or ambiguity is Haram
this is because it leads to what to
dispute to fighting between people of
the scrutiny yeah huh dimensions are
exactly the same however if Robert
doesn't commit to that and the amount of
product is controlled yes yes it is
hello uncertainty and of itself is not
harm it is haram when it leads to
disputes
I think etc cetera okay especially if
the amount of worldly speak okay yes I
will discuss also yeah
this gate is in Oliver al hamdulillah
there is no gambling LM glad the only
element with the insurance is Laurel
Laurel takes place when you pay the
premium but what you receive is not
money you receive a service okay yeah
you receive a service if that is the
case then yeah then if both of you are
clear about what you are going to get
and what you are going to receive yeah
and you are happy with that
okay and the amount of product is
limited so that the transaction can be
overlooked or the hard on in that
transaction can be overlooked this is
provided that we say that it is hard on
in the first place
that's why car insurance we say yeah if
it involves money for money don't do it
it is clear how long Rita
yeah yeah if you are if you are doing
this for gambling it is clear come on
River don't do it however the third
party settlement of the insurances okay
they do not involve money for money okay
it is it involves or they involve what
money for what services okay yeah they
fix your car or something like this so
that if we say that it is haram if we
say that it is how much it can be
overlooked
because of any meat we are not necessity
because of any necessity not necessarily
a high level of necessity okay
a small need will make this problem
overlooked in this transaction if it
involves what aspects of Arriba
in no way so even conscience even car
insurance okay so type I will mention an
exception but it is hard okay the second
thing if it involves gambling yeah then
there is no way if these two elements
are not
but in it involves of uncertainty then
uncertainty that can be overlooked
because of the need yes if you really
need them yeah me too
need a insurance that involves yes River
yes yeah if you need it yeah so what do
you need to do okay for example if the
car insurance is very thin I heard in
some places yes you pay the premium yeah
they give you money
yes if something happens to your car
they don't give you service okay which
which is clear that it is about me money
for more money yes yeah it is clear Reba
so what we what do we say because you
need to have a car yeah that's it yes we
say accumulate the money that you have
paid yes
yeah first of all we say don't enter
into that transaction with the intention
to receive the money and to benefit from
the money okay yeah yes enter that
transaction with the intention that it
is what this is a necessity necessity
okay yeah yes I hadn't been at a
necessity you wouldn't go into that
transaction yeah okay okay this is one
thing the other thing is yeah don't yes
once you receive a compensation yes try
to accumulate how much you have paid the
money that you have paid yeah and taste
from the compensation what is equal to
what you have taken yeah okay also what
you have taste okay Kate what you have
paid in only so imagine for the past
five years you have paid let us say what
sums to what sums up to seven thousand
pounds
yes and then you got recompensation or
compensation from the insurance company
for a theft or fire or whatever okay
yeah you got a compensation of twenty
thousand pounds yes
cake from the 20,000 pounds 7,000 pounds
which you have paid so far okay okay and
the rest get rid of it if you don't
enter enough say see if you talk if you
take a good then it delivered let me get
this right so because I heard you say
maybe little something you said that if
it involves a labor and Gamble Inc
abstain from the total total are you so
are you saying that people if they see
that the insurance involves these they
should abstain from driving or are you
saying that generally what I am saying
is that say if insurance involves a
river yeah or gambling then we should
try see if there is any in transaction
that involves a river or gambling
because these are the top two harmless
apart from cheating yes yeah then we
should abstain from that transaction so
the best includes abstain obvious is
however if we have to do that
transaction yes by it all we have to do
it so it's not about the fatwa that's
because of necessity yeah no you have to
do it okay by it all you have to do
that's a transaction for example trading
between companies you have to have LLC
okay little credit yes that in some
scenarios it might involve RIBA yeah so
it's not about many people call chef I
have to do Lacs [ __ ] halal or Haram I
say Habibi can you avoid it
no they say no by the way I show them
why are you asking me now then Jeff why
yeah don't take rubber stamp from me you
need to ask me how can I minimize the
harm or how can I give it it yes
so if that is the case regarding to
driving cars that involve this kind of
insurance
then if River was involved then we say
how to resolve this issue
take whatever amount of money that you
have made in order not to take so you're
going to be map to document the shepherd
take the following steps whatever you
gave takes on the rest into
yes yeah yes okay that's that's true I'm
gay was coming to again we saw your
necessity by the mothers and said see
some people say in the previous the
sister she could leave the job and find
another job
yeah but again like I said before it's
easier for you if we're talking about
you driving a car yeah it's easier for
you to actually leave your car yeah
now let's see right you see you know I
don't drive anymore yeah it's easier
because you've got public transport da
da da
but that's if there was a need for her
to leave a job she needs time to find
another job
it will come the cost of a family being
affected here and Shapley famous entity
is it really a necessity to the car
because we can see that there is a bus
there is coaches there is trains there
is taxi you can walk it's actually
better for the environment is you're
walking yeah so how do we determine the
sensitive out of this yeah see in terms
of necessity this is something is
colours should decide yeah so I make any
layman yeah not any lame okay okay all
right this is one thing the other thing
is if the pencil from one situation to
another situation one context to another
context okay so what might be necessary
here might not be necessary there what
might be necessity there might not be
necessary yeah for some people a car is
not a necessity maybe for other people
coordinate changes yes it's also about
you say no car is necessity or not is
none life exactly and you start fighting
over this exactly so we can say like if
the fact that you gave on specific
situation this is what something the
scholars decide yeah on specific
circumstance yes you know and then each
person can take it and apply it on them
so about velocity teacher knowledge I
love it I love it I mean in a very well
way inshallah
anything else that we can add on this is
a colossal lassi yeah barbacoa
vocational anywhere within tight like on
site as well as lecture lovely okay what
is this if you want to send any
questions this is in your other
authorship at hotmail.com insha'Allah
we'll answer your question and so next
time as normally let me to like that
title for me and shall hate them I have
that
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo hey give me one I'm
Chucky subscribe